I want to mention you know our second
robot uh stretch yeah tell me about
stretch what stretch who stretch stretch
started differently than spot you know
spot we built because we had Decades of
experience building quadrupeds we just
we had it in our blood we had to build a
quadruped product but we had to go
figure out what the application was and
we actually discovered this this Factory
Patrol application uh basically
preventative maintenance by seeing what
our customers did with it
stretch is very different we started
knowing that there was warehouses all
over the world there's shipping
containers moving all around the world
full of boxes that are mostly being
moved by hand
by some estimates we think there's a
trillion boxes cardboard boxes shipped
around the world each year and a lot of
it's done manually
it became clear early on
that there was an opportunity for a
mobile robot in here to move boxes
around
and the commercial experience has been
very different between stretch and with
spot
as soon as we started talking to
people uh potential customers about what
stretch was going to be used for they
immediately started saying oh I'll buy
I'll buy that Roma you know in fact I'm
going to put in an order for for 20
right now we just started shipping the
robot in January
after you know several years of
development well this year this year so
our first deliveries of stretch to
customers were DHL and Maersk in January
we're we're delivering the Gap right now
and we have about seven or eight other
customers all who've already agreed in
advance to buy between 10 and 28 robots
and so we've already got commitments for
you know a couple hundred of these
robots
this one's going to go right it's so
obvious that there's a need and we're
not just going to unload trucks we're
going to do any box moving task in the
warehouse and so it too will be a
multi-purpose robot and we'll eventually
have it doing palletizing or
de-palletizing or loading trucks or
unloading trucks
there's definitely thousands of robots
there's probably tens of thousands of
robots of this in in the future so it's
going to be profitable can you describe
what stretch looks like it looks like a
big strong uh robot arm on a mobile base
the base is about the size of a pallet
and we wanted it to be the size of a
palette because that's what lives in
warehouses right pallets of goods
sitting everywhere so we it needed to be
able to fit in that space it's not a
legged mobile not a legged robot so it
was our first
it was actually
um
a bit of a
uh commitment from us a challenge for us
to build a non-balancing robot
to do the much easier problem and to put
to do away well because it wasn't you
know it wasn't going to have this
balance problem and in fact the very
first version of the logistics robot we
built was a balancing robot and that's
called handle and there's that thing was
epic oh it's a beautiful machine it's an
incredible machine so it was uh
I mean it looks epic it looks like a out
of uh uh I mean out of the sci-fi movie
of some sorts I mean just can you
actually just Linger on the like the
design of that thing because that's
another leap into something you probably
haven't done it's a different kind of
balancing yeah so let me I I love I love
talking about the history of how a
handle came about because it connects
all of our robots actually
so
um I'm going to start with Atlas when we
when we had Atlas getting fairly far
along we wanted to understand I was
telling you earlier the challenge of the
human form is you have this Mass up high
and balancing that inertia that mass up
high is its own unique Challenge and so
we started trying to get atlas to
balance standing on one foot like on a
balance beam using its arms like this
and yeah you can do this I'm sure I can
do this right like if you walk in a
tightrope
how do you do that balance
so that's sort of you know controlling
the inertia controlling the momentum of
the robot
we were starting to figure that out on
Atlas
and so our first concept of handle which
was a robot that was going to be on two
wheels so it had to balance
that it was going to have a big long arm
so it could reach a box at the top of a
truck
and it was gonna it needed yet another
counterbalance
a big tail to help it balance while it
was using its arm
so the reason why this robot sort of
looks epic some people said it looked
like an ostrich or maybe an ostrich
moving around
was the wheels the Le it has legs so it
can extend its legs
so it's wheels on legs we always wanted
to build wheels on legs it had a tail
and it had this arm and they're all
moving simultaneously and in
coordination to maintain balance because
we had figured out the mathematics of
doing this momentum control how to
maintain that balance and so part of the
reason why we built this two-legged
robot was we had figured this thing out
we wanted to see it in this kind of
machine and we thought maybe this kind
of machine would be good in a warehouse
and so we built it and it's a beautiful
machine it moves in a graceful way like
nothing else we've built
but it wasn't the right machine for a
logistics application we decided it was
too slow
and couldn't pick boxes fast enough
basically and it was doing beautifully
with Elegance but it just wasn't
efficient enough so we let it go yeah
but I think we'll come back to that
machine eventually the fact that it's
possible the fact that he showed that
you could do so many things at the same
time in coordination and so beautifully
there's something there yeah that was a
demonstration of what is possible
basically we made a hard decision and
this was really kind of a hard-nosed
business decision it was it was it
indicated us
not doing it just for the beauty of the
mathematics or the Curiosity but no we
actually need to build a business that
could make money in the long run and so
we ended up building stretch which has a
big heavy base with a giant battery in
the base of it that allows it to run for
two two shifts 16 hours worth of
operation
and that big battery is sort of helps it
stay balanced right so you can move a 50
pound box around with its arm and not
tip over um
it's omnidirectional it can move in any
direction so it has a nice suspension
built into it so it can deal with
you know gaps or things on the floor and
roll over it but it's a but it's not a
balancing robot it's a mobile robot arm
that can work to carry it or pick or
place a box up to 50 pounds anywhere in
the warehouse
from take a box from point A to point B
anywhere yeah palletize de-paletize
we're starting with unloading trucks
because there's so many trucks and
containers that where goods are shipped
and it's a brutal job you know in the
summer it can be 120 degrees inside that
container people don't want to do that
job
um and it's back breaking labor right
again these can be up to 50 pound boxes
um and so
we feel like this is a productivity
enhancer
and for the people who used to do that
job unloading trucks
they're actually operating the robot now
and so by building robots that are easy
to control
and it doesn't take an advanced degree
to manage
you can become a robot operator and so
as we we've introduced these robots to
both DHL and mariskin Gap the warehouse
workers who were doing that that manual
labor are now the robot operators and so
we see this as ultimately a benefit to
them as well
can you say how much stretch cost
um
not yet but I will say that uh we when
we engage with our customers they'll be
able to see a return on investment in
typically two years okay so that's
something you're constantly thinking
about how yeah and I suppose you have to
do the same kind of thinking with spot
so it seems like we stretch the
application is
like directly obvious not to slam dunk
yeah and so you can you have a little
more flexibility well I think we know
the target we know what we're going
after yeah and with spot it took us a
while to figure out what we were going
after